welcome everybody
to the world's most popular hit show
make ethan laugh
that scared me dude i didn't realize
there was so much excitement for the
show
today's today on our uh
first episode
we're gonna be joined by lots of members
and a few members of the cast in the
pursuit to make ethan laugh
each contestant that successfully makes
ethan laugh gets 100
dollars crisp
non-covety bill
i can personally guarantee there's no
covet on these bills
um thank you for sponsoring us today
liquid iv and ridge
this is of course the shoot off of the
wildly popular segment we were doing
make ethan laugh when we said let's put
it together in a show format
get all of our members on discord
together and see who's got what it takes
come on everybody give it up
make either laugh all right got some
sound effects some clapping
thank you all right they're excited lots
of excitement in the crowd here today
folks
well without further ado let's get right
into it
should i start from the top of this list
here with ari
yes we have ari
ari oh by the way if you guys are
wondering how this works
if you become a member you can join our
discord and from the discord you submit
your application to be a contestant i'll
make either layer that's right thanks
everybody glad to have you here okay
all right ari
ari is a 22 year old who has a funny
story about date and pooping ari how are
you
i'm really great ethan how are you i'm
fantastic you happy to be here
oh ecstatic i've been a fan of you since
the jeff dunham days wow
wow we've got a real
real true fan here ari
jew are you jewish ari that's a jewish
kind of israeli name
no i i wish i'm not i'm i'm puerto rican
ari is that that must be short for
something then
it is it's short for ariana but i go by
so you wish you were jewish you forsake
your puerto rican heritage for jewish
heritage if you could
i mean
i've always liked jewish guys so hey
i'm just like trisha
now may i ask you something ari
there's a lot of misconception about the
how jewish men are packing heat some
people are saying they're small i've
heard reports saying they're large in
your experience how do jewish men uh
fair in the penis department
i'd say that they are above average
let's hit a round of applause please
zach come on
we would love to hear it already we love
ari she knows she's here she's saying
all the right things folks
oh man
all right ari are you ready to try to
win a hundred dollars
hell yeah okay
when you're gonna hear the sound that
zach is gonna play what is the sound
zack
the ring the bell is gonna let you know
when your one minute starts i'll give
you a countdown too okay here we go all
right go ahead all set good all right in
three two one go
so basically i was on a date with my
boyfriend at the time and he took me to
this burger joint that was called
jackson hole and they had these 1.5
pound burgers which is like one percent
of my body weight so i ordered my own
burger and we were sitting and talking
and he started opening up to me about
like trauma and really really deep
emotional [ __ ] and all of a sudden
because of like the beef and the gravy
and stuff i shot my pants but like
slowly but also all at once and i was
wearing a bodycon maxi dress so the [ __ ]
was all like compacted in between my ass
cheeks so i had to like hobble over to
the bathroom and scoop it out using my
soiled underwear and like clean myself
up and some of the poop got on the hem
of the dress so i finished the date but
then i made him drive me to target so i
could get another outfit
but
um
i was like so mortified and then when he
was driving me home i actually like shot
myself again
and i cried but i like died with my
secret like i didn't tell him and like
we went home the whole time and the car
was like stinking
and then he dropped me off all right i'm
sorry that's one minute that's one
minute
you know what
you didn't get me to laugh but i was
captivated by the story and i have some
follow-ups
you shake your pants at jack hole what
was it called
it was called jackson hole it was yeah
that almost
now he now he was opening up about
trauma and meanwhile you were not
listening at all were you
i was having bubble guts ethan i was
really going through it do you know what
caused the awful
do you know what caused it
um yeah it was definitely the burger and
i had it with like beef and mushrooms
and all this stuff it really just
it ran through me like a train and then
and then you made him take you to target
to buy new clothes
yes i did and you're and you think he
didn't know you [ __ ] yourself i mean he
must have smelled it definitely knew
yeah
i mean no the first time he did it the
first time he didn't know because i i
cleaned up really well and i had like
perfume in my bag and everything i was
really like
you could smell [ __ ]
no but the mortifying part was when it
got stuck like i was wearing this dress
that like made everything why wouldn't
you just want to go home i don't know
why you would want to spend any more
time out and go to target and stuff that
confuses me because i didn't want to i
didn't want to like ruin the mood i
don't like the guy are you and so what
happened with the guy are you guys
together
oh no we are not we it ended really
badly he broke up with me because he was
cheating on me with a bunch of people so
um do you think it had anything to do
with the [ __ ] the pants or no
no i actually it was kind of an inside
joke for the remainder of the
relationship so it was it was kind of a
good thing oh it was a good thing well
i'm happy to hear that ari thank you for
sharing your story with us today you
know i'm trying really hard we got a lot
of contestants and i'm not trying to go
broke but ari i wish you the best thank
you so much
and uh remember
yeah do you do you frequently [ __ ] your
pants or was that the only time that's
happened
um no that's one of like well other than
i was like a child like yeah that's like
the only time in my adult life i just
find it interesting that you can just
eat a burger and then immediately [ __ ]
your pants out that make me think maybe
it had happened before
okay well i don't know well i wish you
well and uh lots of love out there from
big uh big penis jewish boys all right
thank you ethan what do you mean what
that
big pizza
was this guy jewish
by the way
um
no he was not oh well there's the
whatever you know
water under the bridge
all right yeah exactly thank you
thank you dan
thank you h3 crew all right take care
bye-bye appreciate the opportunity bye
well unfortunately she is not going to
be making a hundred dollars today but
we do thank her for her time
next up it is a tragic
next up we have melchor now what the
never met of melchor yeah that
that's me i only know me and my dad
what's your heritage what kind of what's
the
what's the root of that name
well uh melchior was one of the three
kings in the bible melchor i guess would
be the hispanic version
okay
so i'm i'm a junior was he a good king
or one of those shitty kings
i'm not very familiar with biblical
literature
he
he uh he was the one who met baby jesus
he was the one that one of the three
wise men follow the star oh he's one of
the good ones yeah good for him yeah in
fact in fact i think it was uh
the one about gold the one who had gold
he wasn't any of that frankincense and
myrrh [ __ ] he brought the he brought
the real it'd be kind of fun
baby i was just thinking it'd be kind of
[ __ ] up if your dad named you after
some [ __ ] king but we're glad he's one
of the good ones
so melchor is a 28 year old
finder
okay he has a you have a very funny
story about when you are working in a
restaurant is that right
yes sir yep hey
you know the rules you hear the ring of
the bell you'll have one minute to make
me laugh you want a hundred dollars if
you do if you don't you'll be dis you'll
be dismissed in disgrace
are you ready melchor one of the three
kings of jesus with the gold the one
with the gold all right i'm ready all
right let's do this i'll catch you in in
three two one go
so i'm working uh uh making my rounds i
uh get stopped by somebody not from my
section this guy is asking for the bread
oh i work at outback so everyone knows
the bread is delicious um so he asked
for a refill i said no problem i go over
to the back you know we stick a knife in
the bread and we just walk it over the
bread board's already on the table
so i drop it off the guy who asked for
the bread immediately takes the knife
out and he puts his first two fingers in
and he's you know kind of going in deep
with it
and
you know without uh breaking eye contact
with me
he
just starts going in deep and he's like
oh yeah that's good brad
and i'm just i'm stunned uh the guys in
uh in the back i had barely time to run
to the back because i was holding in my
laughter and uh
he goes
uh
and
everyone's just trying to figure out
what's going on i tell them the story
and they go one by one i'm sorry that's
already figure out who fingered the
so bread fingered the bread
is this did this really happen to you
absolutely i can't make this up uh the
guy who asked for the bread
uh
was was the one who fingered the bread
his guests were appalled
i think it was well to be fair
to be fair uh it is good bread as you
pointed out
but thank you mel yeah yeah it's good
brad and you know i
you know
i guarantee you that and it would
someone's probably put their dick in a
hot loaf before
so
not that big of a difference melchor
thank you so much for your attempt to
make me laugh i'm a stonewall i'm
impenetrable
thank you i'm sorry it's gonna be a hard
one i'm sorry that uh you had to see
that happen and i uh wish you all the
best okay you're one of the good ones
all right
god bless
you
tough crowd today i'm i'm holding strong
zero for two
holding strong fingering the bread
i was a little confused by that story
he was well
it sounds like he just once was a waiter
and a dude fingered a loaf of bread and
made eye contact with him fingered in
like a sexual way i guess i think yeah i
think he had to be there kind of thing i
think the story i thought the story was
going towards him like cutting his own
fingers off or something i really
thought that's where we were headed but
yeah
you guys never finger a loaf of bread
before it's a good time
excuse me
i've never i mean not like that
certainly not but i definitely could see
why
i
love bread okay up next cam grants we
love cam grants you know him
he's a popular fixture in our discord he
is always making memes and
and what some of the best stuff you've
seen h3 related content
uh he is the meme master he is cam
grants
what's the what's the what's the what's
up h3h3
let me tell you
cam grants first of all
thank you for all you've done for the h3
nation we would love to see you hey
thank you
you work for adults
right
uh freelance there yeah i used to work
there full-time but uh now i work for
the lottery now and i uh freelance it
ultimately does the lottery pay you
better
way better but let's not talk money come
on i'm trying to earn some money i'm not
trying to talk it
no i'm trying to make you giggle
yeah okay fair enough i'm glad you're
getting paid you know i'd be like i'd be
like [ __ ] the lottery if they're not
paying you more it's like you know
they're swimming in it
listen times are tough it's like [ __ ]
you the but
the bonus is at like a billion dollars
good good for you
all right you've got a uh let's see you
have a very you have a few funny memes
as well as a meme video oh interesting
entry
so how do you i prefer
i prefer you watch the video first
because that kind of really is like the
bulk of time it's like 30 seconds or so
and then you can just enjoy the memes at
your leisure
okay fantastic this is exciting i gotta
warn you dude if i don't win that
hundred bucks i'm gonna be like one of
those imaginative people saying yeah man
you really fell off
you should've gave me 100 bucks for
giggling bro you're gonna make an
exposed video my imagination's on the
line here okay i don't wanna i don't
wanna i don't need another one of those
in my comments
oh i know
okay
um all right so i mean the video is 33
seconds so i guess we'll just take that
off the clock okay hit that bell hit
that bell boys all right all right cam
grants are you ready to get started
let's [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
i guess yep baby yeah baby yeah your
hidden place so just whenever you're
ready okay here we go surprise from
heaven i already like birthday ethan
it's me the ghost of your living father
gary
you look just as beautiful as you did
when you were a little girl
i watch over you and shoe and ice and
the dogs every day
i'm so proud of how far you've come
ethan
you married the most most most most most
genius woman in the whole world
trisha paytas
don't forget to say your prayers
papa bless
he got him money definitely
[Music]
yo i did not expect that i knew what
this video was but i did not expect to
see my own dad's face
who is very much alive as you pointed
out by the way
yeah
give me a hologram living just ask star
wars trisha
peters god the censor don't forget to
say your prayers amazing papa bless
what the [ __ ] dude
how did you make it
uh
after effects and an app called
[ __ ] avatarify or something pretty
talented ted it's pretty awesome man how
much the lottery paint you know can i do
you think i could pay more than them
uh i mean i prefer to take the fun check
over the money check working for you
sometimes but you know just a dream
would you take a substantial pay cut
[Music]
why not i'm just kidding i won't do that
too but i'm trying to get that clout
money
yeah i got cloud pills i don't know what
i don't doubt the lottery's got clout
pills
yeah dude that was some amazing editing
well you already won thank you very much
i need that clout
do you want to join the memes go for it
but yeah i mean why not i mean you
you've earned it
thanks
thank you very much
uh yeah that that that's pretty good
that's good because you know my face was
that [ __ ] up let's be honest
wiki feat influencer
they should have an influencer program
shouldn't they
hey you're right you're patient zero for
it exactly.com
i kind of feel bad about that one i made
that two weeks ago prior to the exact
cancellation yeah yeah drama
[ __ ] hilarious we
love
love
you
zach
that gilfanakis just kind of thrown in
there as well
yeah i was wondering
if there's any other promises another
jax that's exactly yes did you turn
these white gentlemen these gentlemen i
know are black did you turn them white
yeah that's a bit you did problematic
i'm sorry did that feel wrong doing that
very yeah well actually hold on full
disclosure i found a photo shop of it
roll reversal otherwise so i just threw
his face on it um
good but
peace and love to those guys well cam
grants peace and love to you you win and
we will our first one stay on the line
talk to dan one of these guys will get
you we'll get your info we'll send you
100 fresh clamorinos clamorino
[Applause]
he cracks me up all the time
yeah to be i
i'd be a fool not to scoop him up i
think
oh my mom is calling me she must have
seen that bit
hey mom
hey mom i'm live i'm live on the show
right now
i'm
live on the podcast do you want to say
anything put it on speaker yeah
uh well i'm out i'm downtown l.a at the
jewelry mart i look like a space age
person with the mask and the advisor and
i was birthday shopping for you for ela
oh well
well this is live so
she's going to see this
you said you were
you said you were going to buy her a toe
ring
yeah
would she wear something like that
i think
i don't think either would wear a toe
ring oh kind of
sexy does she have pierced ears she does
have pierced ears i would not get the
toe ring
but okay we just we just did i want to
smell feet
we just did a bit about that so i was
wondering if you're calling about that
so i'm gonna go back to the show but
like uh yeah no toe rings probably
okay all right thank you and by the way
i shop at free people
oh you do
yes is it is it expensive as trisha says
it's
some i mean it depends on what you buy
if you buy a code it's going to cost you
that much i mean it's it's a little
pricey but are you a free person
i am a free person but i'm mostly an
anthropology person now oh yeah okay
let's not okay we
thank you mom
all right take care love you too
how about that exciting mom ladies and
gentlemen
all right
okay
what the [ __ ] was that someone on the
phone what was that
is someone in
someone's in here
yes we have t
on the line t wants to ram anonymous
because she's in law school what are you
studying t
probably law
i mean aren't there different
disciplines of law
isn't there
there are
i don't know
yet i'm thinking criminal
but let's see so do you want to work for
like do you want to defend criminals or
prosecute criminals you know what i mean
defend
you want to defend the criminals so you
you want to so in other words you want
to get paid you want to get paid
i mean maybe but i plan on like working
with them actually i shouldn't say
because i don't know you're anonymous
god damn it
okay
i want to work with uh mostly indigenous
offenders and
because yeah there's a lot of them oh oh
you you know
you just want to help them out like you
want to specialize in indigenous defense
yeah
why did you why were you afraid to say
that i'm curious
because i have a lot of friends who
watch the podcast and i just don't
yeah
okay well t
whoever you are
has a funny yet interesting story about
a sexual encounter involving smelling
fetish
wow we love it we love it
zach says we can hear your stream maybe
you can mute your stream
oh really yeah just
i don't think it's a stream i think are
you not wearing headphones
oh yeah i'm not wearing a head that's
what's going on that's all right i'll
just we won't hear it when she's telling
the story so
t
hit me
with the story well let me count here
here we go okay when you hear the about
you know the rules when you hit the bell
you have one minute to make ethan laugh
if you're making the lap you want a
hundred dollars all right t let's hear
what you got right
ready in three two one go
okay so there's this guy in high school
that i always want to [ __ ] like he was
just a babe but um never did in high
school i went away to university came
home for the summer like we saw each
other out he asked me to go home with
him
um
so i'm like
freaking out we're making out you know
pussy's throbbing
and
um
he's sliding his hand down my stomach
and he starts fingering my belly button
and i'm like wrong whole bud like what's
going on here
um and then he starts sucking on my
belly button ring and i'm just what is
happening
um
then he goes down on me and he's
literally like nibbling on
my puss i'm like okay you're not
supposed to actually eat it
he took his finger put it in my [ __ ]
took that same finger and put it right
back in my [ __ ] and i'm like lying
right on like i just knew my fate was
sealed then like i'm gonna have a yeast
infection and if you ask me that's a
hate [ __ ] because like you wouldn't do
that to someone you didn't hate right
that's time i'm afraid i was captivated
by your story
i don't think it's a hate [ __ ] he sounds
like a dude that like
i just i mean does this guy
you would assume this guy probably gets
a lot of tail judging by how interested
you were with him right
yeah like you know he was the one
everybody wanted
to have and i was it was the most
bizarre encounter ever i'm like this is
what all the hype was about i'm walking
away with a yeasty like so so do you
would you do you think he uh
yeah he should have called it a you see
her in the story i probably would have
done it yeah did you end up getting a
yeast infection
oh [ __ ] yeah damn just one finger it's
incredible men have so much power over
your body it's just one finger in the
wrong place and boom you're at the
doctor
i know he violated me in every way man
like he like finished in me and was like
so you're gonna get plan b tomorrow
right
maybe it was a hate [ __ ] jesus does he
think it was i don't know what i ever
maybe it's not personal though maybe
it's not personal maybe he's just i mean
it sounds like a sick guy why would he
try to [ __ ] your belly button like uh
did he
like that just do you think he got
confused or
like how can you though like really
i think he was fingering your belly
button
yes and i was so confused i was just
lying there in shock like what is even
happening right now it's funny because
you described you were so turned on he
could have pretty much done anything
straightforward and it would have been
good but he ended up yeah like eating
out your belly button fingering your
butthole into your vag
nibbling on your vet like doing all the
crazy [ __ ] all the wrong things the
goddamn i know and the worst thing is
again
you [ __ ] wait what
yeah was it better the second time
uh
yeah i think maybe like he realized like
what he did like wasn't cool for like a
random [ __ ] like maybe with a girlfriend
if like that's something you're into but
like
i feel like he had did you ever talk to
him about it at first or were you just
like let's try it let's give it another
shot and see what it looks like
i never brought it up to him yeah it's
nice to be handsome you know
if someone saved me
like like i'm sorry but it's [ __ ]
nice to be handsome like
you know i watch the bachelorette i've
been watching the bachelorette and they
go
and then like they always fall in love
with the most handsome guy on the show
and they go there's just something about
him we just connect it's like no he's
just [ __ ] like super handsome like
they're always so dumb they have no
connection and here you are letting a
man [ __ ] your belly button and you're
going back for seconds you know the life
is not fair
but you know what it's just like zach
said like you know when you're horny
enough it don't matter you'll go for it
[ __ ] yes
you're right so did you finish up during
that first session
honestly i can't even remember i was
like pretty drunk but
nice
oh my gosh
what is he doing
so um okay fantastic well um
yeah i i have a feeling he was just
excited probably he was drunk it sounds
like you guys were drunk and you know
i don't think it was a hate [ __ ] but hey
what what do i know he's got it sounds
like he's got antra man syndrome where
he just gets away with anything does he
have a good personality
yeah like
like i just don't get it i've never seen
this belly button thing on pornhub i've
never heard of this before in my life
like does anybody
out there have a similar experience i
gotta say i think he was drunk and he
just
you think he just missed i think he just
missed because it isn't a thing
i know it's hard to believe but like i
think that's what happened
so like he goes from playing with my
nipple to sliding his hand down like
a few centimeters or whatever a few
inches
and he's like yep that's definitely pus
the only other explanation is that like
he was in a recent relationship where
the girl liked that stuff and sometimes
you're like oh she likes it everybody
likes it
yeah every girl also loves a surprise
finger in the [ __ ]
some do
got him but was it dry it wouldn't dry
huh
yeah like i was just that's not i don't
know
shook at that point so
well he got you back in the bed so
congratulations to him would you marry
him if he asked you straight up be
honest
no he just got married too
what's his name give me his full name
i'm just kidding
i just want this newlywed to hear this
story well she's obviously been through
the ringer too so shout out to her
all right
well t i've loved uh
being on the phone with you good and i
uh say god bless to all the indigenous
people that you'll be uh defending
and
you and i wish you
and um
and uh all your future yeasties uh well
and quick recoveries from them all all
right
no more since then thank you very
you much care god bless you
wow yeasty is a new one i like that wow
great song at a yeasty
great soundbite
[Laughter]
see that's the thing you guys don't be
too jealous of handsome guys because
this is the type of [ __ ] they get up to
like really handsome beautiful men you
know like movie star level [ __ ] they get
into weird [ __ ] like this and nobody
ever stops them it's the same thing as
like super beautiful women you go
they're just so dumb and they don't do
anything and they just like you know
they just lay there like fish that's
like
you know that's the uh
right so that's what guys do they just
go straight for the [ __ ] drive love
it
don't love it i feel like that's a zack
move to go for the [ __ ] dry nah you
can't go dry man
you know maybe a little bit you know
that at least zach knows you can't go
drunk he's a gentleman
[Laughter]
so two things real quick one uh somebody
donated 20 in the chat and said i want
to do some impressions to make ethan
laugh um thank you for the 20 however
uh just in case you missed it at the top
of the show the way to get on as a
contestant is to become a member and to
um join the discord and in there you
will see uh zach a b and ian they're the
one organizing all of this
um
we're pretty full up on contestants
today but if you want to do it for next
time because i think this is going to be
an ongoing thing um that's the way to do
it and then also uh we're at 30 minutes
if you want to do our ad reads real
quick let's do our ad reads to make all
this possible
show like this is very expensive to put
on
giving away a hundred dollars so far
tough crowd today
the stories are great though
yeah i know it's been engaging even if
all right let's let's thank our sponsors
let's start here with liquid iv
uh this is
i love liquid iv comes like this you
open it up
the bag is kind of the same tone as the
green screen right now so you get these
little tubes right
and you've got different flavors
different formulas this one for example
is super hydration
one stick
apparently equals two to three times
more hydration than a glass of water so
you just pop that in there right
this is one the one that i really like
is they've got a like energy boost one
you know what flavor that is dan the
energy boost it's got like caffeine
and um
i forget what the flavor was it was good
though and all the b12 and [ __ ] and it
it wakes you up dude especially if you
don't like coffee or if you just want to
concentrate and it's much more hydrating
because it's in water you know what i
mean
boom
love it hydrated pumped yakked yolked
so you know and then they've got a like
a um
an immune boost one those are the three
flavors i have energy immune boost and
hydration
formulated for your pleasure
tastes great you feel great
and um
what more really can i say about liquid
iv it's a fantastic product it's clean
it is non-gmo
which uh
says a lot it's powder so it's non-gmo
you know give it a shot let me try
another slug here because i'm getting
i'm losing some juice here in the middle
of the show let me just pick myself up
liquid i like it i really like it i'm
not i'm not playing it up i do genuinely
like it and i drink one pretty much
every day the the um the energy one
middle of the day dude
you get that second uh second wave easy
second wind okay
uh let's see they've got three delicious
flavors sweet and juicy guava crisp
watermelon and comforting apple pie they
contain five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks but
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and less sugar than an apple made with
clean ingredients non-gmo vegan and free
of gluten dairy and soy
that's what i'm talking about
liquid iv is available nationwide at
walmart in the beverage section or you
can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use code h3 at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use the
code h3 liquidity.com
promo code h3 better get better
hydration today at liquidity.com promo
code h3
[Music]
i love sponsors when i really actually
like their product
which is always
we love all of our sponsors i'm not
going to tell you the ones i don't like
but these are the these are the ones
that i do like
well look there's some sponsors i'll
straight up tell you i don't use their i
don't really use their service sometimes
it's like
just to hypothetically talk it's like um
menstrual
yeah maybe i'll stop you're right zach
uh speaking of products that i love and
use myself ridge ridge ridge wallop it's
sleek it's futuristic it's right now
it's happening it's ridge wallets
okay
look it's made of the super
durable metal
it's lightweight
it's slick you put your cards in here
boom see
see put your cards in there yep
it's got a money clip
when you want to use your client your
card you slide them out you slide them
in that's it you don't want a huge
wallet with all these coins i can't
stand having a chunky wallet that's why
i love ridge because it's like you know
i started turn like carrying a bag with
me because i have all this [ __ ]
and i'm just getting tired of carrying
[ __ ] around so i kind of swung the other
way and now i'm loving the ridge because
it's like boom out the door phone ridge
out the door
holds 12 cards up to 12 cards plus room
for cash there's over 20 colors and
styles including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium let me show you these because
they're actually pretty cool
ridge i use the burnt titanium ridge.com
h3 take a look at these really cool
designs and colors bro oh there's a new
one damascus that's pretty sweet
damascus
i hope that's not fake damascus what is
damascus
it's uh i think it's supposed to be like
damascus steel which is like uh
you know the ancient uh super sharp
blades oh they're making a mythical
steel yeah exactly
it's like the real it's like valerian
steel but uh but for real oh it's real
that i'm sure it's real it's what's on
the sword of bell sent yeah
no i don't think so no that that thing
couldn't cut it that was just that was
cold steel
that sort
she sent me couldn't cut a
slice of bread
anyway
they got over 30 colors in styles
i love it but don't take my word for it
there's over thirty thousand five star
reviews the durable material means each
wallet comes with a lifetime warranty
you could buy this one wallet and carry
it for life the ridge team is so
confident you'll like it they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and if you
don't love it you could send it back for
a full refund
boom dude
come on oh yeah
got 10 off today and free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com h3that's ridge dot com slash
h3 use code h3 ridge wallet we love you
and all right who are you kidding huh
did they be really say that or is that a
drone no that was a sound bite yeah i
was like dude that's kind of
inappropriate they just
come in with that so forcefully but uh
thank you zach now i see ian's
frustration
the use of sound bites yeah
ian endured years of that [ __ ] and now
he's just a [ __ ] robot
all right
moving on you know let's do one of you
guys now
because we've done
the you know the crew gets a shot to 100
bucks too and what we've thought is
they'll present a video
so we have some media here so zach you
want to introduce your video for us
thanks
i think it kind of speaks for itself
it's a classic because i don't know
oh well you know i've seen this but okay
let's see if i can
let's see if i can endure this classic
best cry ever wow 80 million views huh
80 million views i mean yeah it's worth
it do we know that the genesis well here
people know it's this cry where he goes
um
do we know the origin of this like where
it came from yes it was on a show called
intervention
and dad's mad because he's gay is that
no
intervention is about uh people that
have drug abuse problems oh i always
thought
i don't know why i thought that dad was
like disowned him because he was gay i
that was always what i assumed
because he seems kind of old school
conservative and how can you tell that
i think there was a similar meme at the
time that that was the background i i
don't know why i just i just always say
he's giving you the benefit of the doubt
maybe maybe i mean you could
okay you had a drug problem i mean [ __ ]
nissi can fix that
can't fix gabe
i mean
that's what the dad is thinking you
know this imaginary scenario
okay all right stop
all right here we go best cry ever come
on ethan let's do this sack for a
hundred dollars here we go because i
know
somewhere deep down in my heart
i still love hold on hold on oh because
i assumed that this guy was gay and he
was like [ __ ] you dad you disown me
because i'm gay
but his dad has addiction problems
and the son is saying i still love you
dad is that right
yes oh it might be the other way around
i i don't know
because why would he be saying okay
whatever i'm getting too deep into this
go ahead ring the bell i'm sorry i'm
ruining your moments
[Laughter]
give me a bell
bell
somewhere deep down in my heart
i still love you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
what's funny is that they thought
this was this big impactful emotional
moment and they pipe in emotional music
you know everyone watching at home just
started bursting laughing
[Music]
but it is kind of a touching
it's very sad
yeah it's touching it
it's just such a shame that he had to
laugh like so goofy even his son was
almost gonna laugh in his face
he's like damn dad i never heard that
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah all right zach you got 100 bucks
for that [ __ ] i'm actually
when zach showed me that that's what his
video was i was like dude he's seen that
a million times he's not gonna laugh but
i was wrong classics work man i guess so
i shouldn't have laughed honestly but i
i gotta try harder that shouldn't have
got by the the
the barrier
all right zach you got 100 bucks all
right thank you
um
let's move it on jason
sergeant saggy sack
25 years old has a thanksgiving story
about a grandpa that he thinks can make
ethan laugh jason
hello jason poppin
sergeant saggy sack do you indeed in
fact have a saggy sack
i am not a sergeant but my sack is sagan
yeah
you're only 25 so
have you always had a saggy sack or do
you think it's something you're aged
into
i used to practice the uh where you wrap
a rope around it and hang pots from your
sack
and meditation
are you serious
no absolutely not uh i don't know it's
just genetics i guess i got a real loose
one oh you do okay
interesting yeah and do you have you
ever got comments on the saggy sack or
is that just kind of something that's
not that big of a deal oh for sure i uh
i'm i'm a part of a sports team and
you know in the showers after the games
sacks are flinging all about and uh you
know you know boys take notice yeah i
mean it must be really saggy if people
actually notice because i feel like this
like how deep how like it goes down
significantly down towards your thighs
yeah i mean i'm a tall dude okay
you know we're getting some we're
getting some sag but i think it's just
the effects of gravity right you know
since i'm a little bit taller up i don't
know maybe gravity's pulling down
there's higher gravity up there
maybe yeah i mean i got a science degree
so i think it adds up
how tall are you
uh six four yeah it's pretty tall
yeah yeah could it just could be just
maybe maybe that your sack is closer to
eye level for these guys and so maybe
they're just face they just got in there
they got a better angle on it yeah
yeah
that could be i've never really
considered others perspectives you know
it's good to put yourself in other
people's shoes
[ __ ] you're right jason
sergeant saggy sack
we're gonna give you one minute
you know the rules when you hear the
bell ring you have one minute to make
ethan laugh you make it live you get a
hundred dollars if you don't we pull the
giant cane and open the chute in the
stage floor and you fall to your death
fair enough all right cool all right
here we go okay i will count you in here
we go in three two one go
so we used to always have thanksgiving
with my grandparents and my grandpa you
know always sat at the head of the table
like this super respected patriarch of
the family like retired marine officer
college professor just a very proper
individual so he finished the blessing
and we all started digging in and i
guess grandpa got a bite that had a bit
too much pepper in it you see him
loading up this monster sneeze and he
fires it off into his napkin
looks away sees that the food that was
in his mouth is now in the yeasty sneeze
rag and just buries it back in bites the
food out and just keeps on going like
nothing happened
everyone at the table starts losing
their [ __ ] just gagging my mom had to
excuse herself go to the bathroom she
ended up puking and grandpa just carried
on like nothing ever happened just
absolute legend so pick up the boss man
grandpa for keeping it real in the
streets
that was really good the chat the chet
knees
yeah i tried a little bit i had i had a
hard time understanding what exactly
happened with grandpa he like he just
he liked
he was eating his food
then he sneezed into the napkin
saw that the food that was in his mouth
is now mixed in with the sneeze in his
napkin
and went back in to eat it out oh he ate
it out of the napkin
disgusting
yeah
everyone was losing it
just trying to hold it in for grandpa to
respect but
my mom had to had to take a step away
hit the bathroom did he notice like or
was he just like i don't give a [ __ ] i
mean he was like he's at that age he's
just like you know it's food like when i
was a kid we didn't have food so you
just eat the food even if it's covered
in mucus man i just go back in i'm
curious i'm curious how how saggy your
grandpa's balls are at this point in
life i mean honestly i can only imagine
yeah one can only drink well someday
you'll find out yourself vietnam and
maybe i'll find well i don't think i'll
find out how saggy the sack is well
you'll find out about that you'll find
out by
your genetics uh catching up with you
we'll see i'll give you measurements
every couple you know years keep
checking in keep checking in update
update yeah send those send those pics
to daniel
yeah
is that interesting
all right you can send it to zach you
can send it to sam well
saggy sack we uh we loved to hear from
you but unfortunately the laughs were
not had
and uh we wish you all
so thank you very much you know he did
make you chuckle uh prior to his actual
uh
a lot of time
thank you very much unfortunately yeah
appreciate y'all thanks for having me on
all right take care
you guys have saggy sacks or tight sacks
mine's pretty high and tight yeah i have
a tight sack yeah
depends i mean yeah temperature it
varies
absolutely but but in general like if i
check now
i mean yeah it really does depend but on
the whole
pretty tight are you guys a left leaning
or right like which one hangs lower than
the other i think my left one is like
substantially larger mm-hmm
substantially i might want to get that
checked out if it's just yeah
it's always been that way
it's not like it's not i don't really
notice a disparity personally i think
i'm i'm pretty balanced
man you must have nice nuts
yeah
all right all right
all right let's move it on
tough crowd today guys i mean here we
have it
on the call who's that hez
yes yes it is
hez is a 20 year old man who has a funny
story
about a bike accident and a trip to
walmart
has
are you going to make me laugh today
we're having a tough day here a tough
crowd we've only given away 200
100 of it was to zach and he didn't
really deserve it but okay
you know i'm gonna try my best and if i
don't make you laugh i'll just give you
a hundred bucks you're gonna give me
whoa
yeah now the pressure's on
all right let's make this interesting
you know the rules all right you hit the
rig of the bell you got a one minute to
make either life be making it live you
gotta have a hundred dollars let's
[ __ ] go i'll catch you in here we go
in three two one hit it
all right so my freshman year of college
i was tricked into a pyramid scheme
selling books door-to-door um and i only
had like 20 to my name this one day uh i
so i bought a bike and i wrote it
downhill because i thought maybe i can
get around and you know knock on more
doors faster uh so i go use them i'm
going downhill and i hit the brakes and
they just don't work at all and i ran
straight into a truck coming off the
highway i flew maybe like 15 feet
through the air and i hit a stop sign
but i was in so much shock at the time i
didn't even realize i was in pain and i
got up and i was like oh my god where's
my bike where's my bike and like 50
people get out of their cars and they're
like oh my god are you okay you need to
sit down i'm like no my bike my bike and
so like they sit me down and the
ambulance shows up and they rip my pants
off because they said i had internal
bleeding in my legs which i did it and
now i'm in my underwear in front of like
50 people i don't know
and then fast forward they let me out of
the hospital without pants so i had to
like run to walmart with no pants on to
try and find somebody to like give me
pants so i could go home because i
didn't know how it was going to go get
anywhere
uh yeah that's my story so far that's
very interesting they cut your pants off
and then let you lose without pants did
they give you a gown or something to
wear
no they i was just in whitey tighties
and a backpack so i
i had they let me go and i saw a police
officer and i asked him for help and i
was like hey and he just like
immediately freaked out and pulled his
gun out on me and i was like no no no i
normally wear pants i swear and he was
like all right man sure and i asked him
for a number for like a taxi and he gave
that to me and the taxi driver had
pulled up and even he was like dude i
don't know if i can give you a ride i'm
like dude i promise i just need i just
need pants i just need to get to walmart
it sounds like a bad dream this normally
doesn't happen yeah it sounds like a
fever dream honestly it's it's something
that doesn't normally happen to people i
don't think it's something you would
dream about like i know everyone has
that dream where they like naked you
know like yeah it sounds like something
and i'm like man so what's the protocol
when they cut off your pants you think
they have more procedure in place when
they well they they asked me they were
like do you like these pants and i was
like i mean they're just khakis i didn't
know they were gonna rip them off and so
they took out a knife and they just
ripped my pants they should have been a
little bit more clear
and i'm like man
i really should have said i love my
pants
but
they were just khakis so i didn't really
care
um
but yeah it was a rough day i i
honestly i i went into that summer with
about seven thousand dollars and i i did
such a bad job
uh i left that summer in the hole two
hundred dollars wow so that's the peril
of getting into that [ __ ] it was rough
damn i'll never do it again i'll never
do the pyramid schemes again i don't
recommend them if you're ever you know
interested and so uh and so how long did
it take you to get home how long were
you pantless
i was pantless for about three hours bro
what i i finally got home and my
roommates
who were like hey man how was your day i
was like man it sucked i had to
i had no pants for like half my day so
far
uh man it was it was rough i i honestly
thinking back on it uh it was the worst
and best thing that's ever happened to
me because it's something i can laugh
about today
but
man
great experience never thought going
pantsless would be a great experience
three hours without pants well
uh hez has uh done it all
i've been everywhere
did you continue shopping without pants
or was that that was out of the question
probably
or continue
i didn't want to steal the pants when i
was in the walmart so i didn't put them
on i just held on to them and got in
line and when i stood in line i was
behind this mom who was with her kid and
they saw me standing behind them with no
pants on holding pants the mom just like
looked at her like she should have put
in the pants she was like she was like
she was like uh billy we gotta go let's
go and they left walking i would have
just put the pants on uh zach is
wondering if you have saggy balls
um i it depends on the weather uh
because if it's cold weather my balls
just like they go into my body oh wow
yeah you got you know what i mean
that one's that's that one's pretty wild
i have to say i've seen first time i
noticed balls going up was like it was
in a porno and i couldn't believe what i
was seeing i had i like
i had to like stop and pause
i mean it's it's very
unusual
the balls
you know like when people like twitch
their ears on on command was it was it
like that like they could just make
their balls go up and down or what do
you well i didn't have that much of an
intimate uh
connection with the person but you know
what has
getting a little bit off track here
thank you so much for your story
and uh save the hundred dollars don't
send me a hundred just in case you ever
need to buy another pair of pants okay
good call
i appreciate it appreciate it ethan and
i love the show and thanks for having me
on i've been a fan since israel thank
you very much thank you
appreciate it all right take care
you guys believe that
the retracting the balls thing no the
three hours without pants you go to
walmart and not put the pants on you
stand in line without pants and
underwear
uh
well
i mean they might think that you're
trying to steal or something well you
just give them the tag yeah i probably
put the pants on i mean they got the
they got the like security
thing on them
oh that's true they're going to have to
take off the little magnet they put tags
on like okay all right you know what has
god bless you
up next we've got lizzie
lizard brain
24 year old has a funny story about her
being a nude model and in our class that
she thinks will make ethan laugh lizzy
are you with us i am hello lizzy
lizard brain
is that some kind of alpha brain type of
thing what is a lizard brain
well um my nickname as a child was
smelly lizard and um i have maybe two
working brain cells at the most so
you you consider yourself a dumb person
well it's more of like i read a lot of
books but sometimes you know just head
empty kind of thing
um and i mean in this story you'll get
to hear one of those uh moments so from
one jew to another as well shalom shalom
all right well you you're a nude model
that's pretty adventurous uh what how
did you how did you get yourself into
being a nude model how did you work up
the courage to do that
well i had a plan at the beginning of
2020 uh before the pandemic went down
and everything i had just gotten a
personal trainer and i decided that 2020
was going to be the year of doing it for
the bit
so i thought that i could you know i
would set up to be this like nude art
model at the studio by my place it was
going to be empowering and i was going
to it was going to be motivation for me
to like get super like you know just
like taught like a bowstring right well
that didn't happen
um
but i forgot i had applied and i ended
up uh doing it as a last-minute fill-in
did they pay you or is it just kind of
like a hey here i am
yes it was paid so it was a three-hour
long class yeah three hours a day
yes did you [ __ ]
i hope you [ __ ] yourself or something
and you just didn't move
i
i mean i was
very very aware of uh what
my body was doing well let's hear the
story let's hear the story
i'm intrigued right okay lizzy you know
the rules when you hear the bell ring
you have one minute to make me laugh if
you make me laugh you get it okay
billion dollars that's right oh that'd
be great all right zach
get ready here we go in three two one go
so i think they had thought that i had
done this before nude modeling when they
had asked me to be a fill-in for this
beginning nude figure drawing class the
first day um which i had not so i didn't
actually know i was supposed to come up
with my own poses on the spot so at one
point they were having me do a section
of one pose per minute and it's three
hour long class right so i was running
out of ideas and i had been in a
standing position and so i just you know
for the bit yes and i was trying to be
creative and i ended up without thinking
bending over into a child's pose and
presenting
my entire [ __ ] and pikachu to this
room like rb special
and i had to stay there for the longest
minute of my life i mean i got great
reviews from the older gentleman right
behind me um he actually personally
thanked me oh
there's a charcoal drawing of my razzle
dazzle somewhere out there and uh yeah i
haven't heard back from them since
well uh ethan laughed i feel like i
i did laugh and you laugh you deserved
that i mean
did you refer to your um your lady parts
as a rb special at one point
uh yeah you know i've got a whole list
of names you know pikachu is kind of the
default do you have big
labia is that what that means libya
labia
surprisingly i actually have an innie so
uh no i don't but i'm sure at that
position anything is you know right it's
all hanging out
nice i felt everything
okay so so what exactly happened you
were doing all these poses and you're
just like uh just in the motions and
then once you are on all fours you're
like oh [ __ ] i'm stuck and this is not
appropriate that is exactly what
happened because it was it was a section
of like it was maybe a 10-minute section
where i was doing one pose a minute
and so i was having to move very freely
it's also a beginning class right so
it's just a bunch of vagrants and [ __ ]
it's not like real artists
so that's the thing it was like a yeah
it was this art school in my
neighborhood and i you know there's a
legit art school and i know they have
like advanced classes and everything i
know one of the students there was um
she was majoring in medical
illustrations so she had to take this
class in order to build her portfolio
that was perfect for her
right exactly she got i mean you know
she was kind of off to the side so she
didn't get like that full view but i
don't know what that um older gentleman
was doing there to be honest
he said thank you
that's [ __ ] did he really thank you
yeah so it's kind of you know it's
strange because you're the only one
there who's naked and you're in a room
of people sitting around you in a circle
and they have to stare at you and like
you're it's a weird situation so nobody
really wants to be awkward and like say
hi to the naked lady in the room but
like you know it's just like a delicate
situation right so at the end of the
class i'm like getting my stuff back on
but i'm still like tits out right and
this guy he just kind of leaned over and
went thank you so much
and i was like
how'd that make you feel
well i mean i mean this man has
so many drawings of me now so
at the same token though like um
it is nice to be thanked
you know listen yeah i
the fact that like you know i was
appreciated because like nobody was
nobody was talking to me right because
it's it's they had an introduction part
of the class where everyone was going
around saying who they were and i
thought they were going to introduce me
but they did
so i was just nameless naked lady so did
you did you see any of his drawings did
you see any of the result of your
of your uh i
i saw a few at one point they kind of
had like a show and tell halfway through
the class while i was on my break
because they're trying to be good about
like giving you breaks
um and i didn't you know i didn't i
hadn't done it before so like i didn't
know how i was supposed to look at them
at one point they were showing examples
of the class and i was able to see
you know and like there was there was
one man who really went all in on the
shading of my nipples
nice which you know it's really
interesting to see what you look like in
the eyes of beginners trying to draw
your body so there were some parts where
i'm like wow i am immortalized in
beautiful
charcoal and then other parts i'm like
oh so so that's that's what i look like
yeah sure dope
so i'm so i'm assuming you never did it
again but uh
but well i have not heard back
on their roster
so who knows maybe they'll call me back
maybe that gentleman really gave me a
raving review
well
lizzy
you succeeded in making me laugh
very strong contestant
i don't think you have a lizard brain i
want to uh i want to correct you on that
one i don't think i i'd like to correct
the record on that one i think you have
a uh a human brain if i can go so far as
to complement yeah
yeah
thank you so much you're very welcome
lizzy um thank you stay on the line are
going to give you one billion dollars
for making me laugh that's right you are
set for life all right
[Laughter]
thank you
you know it'd be pretty funny for
someone like me i assume most nude
models are like kind of i thought
from what i understood they like kind of
fat nasty people because it's more
interesting to draw
but i've never done a new drawing thing
before i have i have not either
but um
but i know i don't know if they prefer
the fat nasty people necessarily but i i
see what you mean there's there's more
uh nuance to draw there nuances exactly
who wants to look at a beautiful naked
woman all day
not me
i imagine if you're a guy you'd have to
chop up a little bit right
well it's a very loppy idea no yeah
that's not the idea i don't think
i don't think so well but i mean if a
girl gets all in all fours and presents
that all to you
they're in a room full of a lot of
people and you know well you don't have
control necessarily dan
okay i'm just trying to defend poor zach
here
[Laughter]
on that hill
interesting
okay moving on we have john
john
parker skull and mortar he's 38 wow what
an old [ __ ]
yeah i'm pretty old man
you're older than me
yeah i'm almost geriatric thanks for
watching i like the uh the retirement
crowd
yeah i just filled out my arp the other
day nice dude we're gonna have to go for
an early bird special together
i'm into it man let's make it happen
denny's baby john barker
38 has a funny poop experience that he
thinks will make me laugh
john what do you do for a living
i am a chef
hey
do you have an early bird special at
your restaurant
uh i don't because i'm very greedy but
for you i could probably make it happen
do you own your own restaurant are you a
chef at the restaurant
i own a food truck and uh a kitchen here
in um indianapolis nice wow good for you
that's cool you're a go-getter
you're one of those go-getter people i
hear about
i mean you might as well try right yeah
yeah of course
the food truck's really popular right
now though eh
yeah no no doubt especially with all the
covid closures and whatnot
and so business is good for you even
despite the pandemic
oh yeah we won best andy every year so
we're always busy
you win the best what
uh the best of indy oh my goodness we're
talking to a legend john baker barker
what's the name of your food truck
oh no one that's our [ __ ] story on the
name of my food truck and the same thing
well you don't have to i just figured
i wanted to give your food truck a shout
out
it's called beach ball barbecue and then
of course i own skull and mortar too
of course
well if i'm ever out in indianapolis i'd
love to try your food it sounds like
it's amazing so congratulations on
having such a prosperous business good
job man
thanks man i appreciate it all right now
let's move on we've got you know the
rules john we have one minute to make me
laugh
when you hear the ring of the bell
you'll start and if you make me laugh
you get a hundred a hundred fresh dollar
bills
i'm gonna go for it all right john
all right let's do this starting in
three two one go
so i made the mistake of eating at a
five dollar channel but china buffet
drink included so three plates in i'm
crapping are cramping hard crapping is
coming but i'm not going to [ __ ] on the
buffet toilet right so i hop in the car
and i head to my mom's because it's
close by but she's not home so i'm a big
dude i'm trying to climb in the windows
and i'm full-blown panicking because i'm
a grown man about to [ __ ] himself
there's no way around this
so i realize i'm not going to make it i
run back to my car and i start looking
for the nearest toilet my friends are
kind of feeding into this panic and i
tokyo drift as hard as i can into the bp
parking lot i run in my ass at maximum
capacity the [ __ ] is breaking the plane
in my [ __ ] here i'm very scared ethan
so i run into the bathroom i pull down
my pants i [ __ ] all over the toilet the
floor everything so i clean myself up
and as i go to flush i see the out of
order sign so there's nothing i can do
it's a complete rectal murder and the
worst part is
i make eye contact with the cashier on
the way out and she saw me she knew and
i even saw her at kroger like a week
later it was a pretty tough situation
you know
you know
you were trying to climb in the windows
of your mom's house
yeah i'm a big guy ethan i'm very large
how tall what's your weight
uh so at the time i was uh let's say i'm
about 6 1 at the time i was probably
pushing like 290. so i'm a little
smaller now but
these windows were high up they were
probably solid like five six feet off
the ground
yeah no i've been there so you walked
into this what what kind of store was it
uh it was a bp
what is bp it's like a gas station oh
okay yeah yeah no we don't have those
around here apparently and so the toilet
was out of order and you blasted on it
anyway that's the that's great
oh yeah dude i had no clue like i mean i
was in such a panic i didn't pay
attention to any signs you know i've
been there man you know what i mean
i've been there i gotta tell you i i
recently i don't know what happened but
i was driving my car
this happened like a year ago i was
going into the office actually to shoot
a podcast coming down from downtown from
a meeting or something
and i was i started cr like i had this
[ __ ] so bad i knew my only my best shot
was just to hit the office straight
i was i started crying i was crying
i was in so much pain
and i was just clenching and praying and
sometimes you when you're on a bench you
just kind of like try to sit and squeeze
like put the pressure yeah the cork the
cork the
the bottle
and i was crying i was praying and i was
just [ __ ]
begging god please if you're there show
me a sign
and i did make it i did make it that day
and i'm glad you made it too man
and thank god for the power of prayer
yeah god actually answered my prayers
that day i'm happy to say
[ __ ] i'm not i mean
mine too
i should be a religious man i'd overlook
that miracle
will you really stay with me later we'll
pray together
let's let's let's say some prayers baby
all right john barker hello my friend i
didn't uh didn't laugh but i appreciate
you and i loved the story and i love
what you're doing in life so keep it up
all right
thanks for the opportunity all right
take care buddy
you too
i'm doing pretty good today
you're handling it man i saw you guys
cracking up back there but i thought i
thought that one was going to get you
for sure he was a good storyteller too
so
you know
i everyone quite you were crying yes
like no i was in so much pain i was so
desperate and i so i didn't want to [ __ ]
my pants so bad because i knew it wasn't
going to be like a nug it was going to
be like a torrent of
it was
from like the frustration or pain
from the pain the discomfort i've been
there man
but you you know it was like when i
actually did take a dump i mean it was
like ecstasy
well i'm just saying the the volume was
[Laughter]
and the consistency was not something
you would want in your car so
i wasn't you know
oh
nasty i would have ruined my whole
[ __ ] day you didn't share that with
us well i think we had like a big guest
or something too
so let's go do one of your guys videos
now uh dan you've got a video you want
to set it up for me uh
no i don't actually i just want you to
watch it cold all right make sure you
have audio
it's one minute six seconds dan
that's all right
pushing it you know the roles around
here
all right here we go dan's video
[Music]
looks like it's hitting his thighs more
than
iron crab
iron crotch kung fu
[Applause]
oh
why is this a discipline iron crotch
i mean to be honest but if if i didn't
get you by now i'm not going to i mean
i'm intrigued to finish
and yeah it's like dude you're not
like what kind of disc what isn't karate
for like uh you know self-defense and
stuff i mean you're just slamming a
log into your 50
kilograms dude which is like what like
120 pounds or something oh there's more
oh they just oh there's others yeah
they're doing all kinds of stuff yeah
obviously
we love it
we love it though
great piece from dan
great submission
all right where are we
we just talked to
um
let me talk you're on avery avery
mega awesome nerd
avery ethan what
avery your 26 year old you have a funny
story about a karen
and thinking
you or somebody else oh there's a
picture for reference you want me to
show this
um
um i would say save it towards the end
okay
sure okay yeah
yeah you know um i'll just queue it up
and and yeah yeah you know
your
dealer's choice yeah
okay avery how are you today are we
feeling confident
um yeah i'm feeling good you know i'm
glad to be back just chilling um i saw
zach's call and saw he needed people and
decided to help didn't even know 100 was
a thing so
uh just looking to make you laugh
hopefully all righty you know the rules
avery you get one minute when the bell
rings you make me laugh you got a
hundred billion dollars wow
all right let's do this i'll catch you
in in three two one go
all right cool so 2018 i'm at las vegas
for nab with me and my boys um some of
them are like minorities other like
white dudes so it looks like i have a
bit of an entourage so we're leaving
like our hotel room in the flamingo and
we passed by this like huge like bridal
and groom party like there's definitely
a bride there and stuff and some dudes
and tuxedos and bridesmaids and all that
and as we're passing by there's this one
lady who like starts whispering to like
the other people like like staring at me
and stuff and then like they all started
whispering and staring at me and then
finally the lady she just breaks down
she's like oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
are you michael orr are you the blind
side guy and like
and like and like ethan
i get the sometimes people think i look
like fat steve urkel or i look like you
know
andre the black nerd or you know i look
like cookie from that one nickelodeon
show but
but i do not look anything like michael
orr or the blindside dude and i was
confused until like halfway through she
kept saying blindside and i realized
what she was talking about i'm like no
wait am i there unfortunately that is
time that's just due one minute damn
time
you can finish the story though go ahead
okay yeah totally so yeah so i totally
not dude i'm not this dude and then at
first she's like oh no come on you're
trying to goof me you're trying to be
coy and i'm like no i'm not i'm not this
dude and then flash is like no you you
are this dude you are the blind side guy
like you're [ __ ] him and then like
even my friend who's like why he's
stepping in he's like hey dude like this
is not michael or this is not the
blindside guy and he finally was gonna
leave me alone so then finally i was
just like [ __ ] it so i was all like you
know what miss
i am the blindside guy
and she's like yes i [ __ ] knew it and
she's all like i knew it i don't see
color i know you kind of play coy and
i'm like what
she thought she didn't see coming i was
like okay lady and then she's all like
you know can you take a picture with my
with my daughter she's getting married
and everything and i'm like yeah you
know i'll get a picture of his daughter
so i keep [ __ ] the [ __ ] with them i
love their names
you know there's i've seen these the
kind of memes on reddit where they're
like they're super drunk and they're
like i took a celebrity photo with
somebody and it doesn't look anything
like them
yeah
it was pretty much like that but they're
sober so i don't even know why and like
it's like and if you see the pictures
ethan you can see them now i guess but
like i look nothing like that oh that's
you okay
yeah i mean i mean
are you a bit you're a big dude i'm
assuming
i get the big dude but it's like
i got a little bit of like a huge guy
you know
you don't look like an athlete
exactly yeah or i don't have the face
like like like i get the tall thing but
she was all like face she's like your
your face matches like
and so it's a
yeah so the [ __ ] with her i was just
like yeah and she kept telling me her
name and i kept [ __ ] it up so first
she's like yeah i'm susan i'm like okay
nice to meet you sam and then i kept
changing like beth and [ __ ]
well during the figure i kept [ __ ] it
up on purpose subtly so they keep having
taken it over and over
and then finally after they got a
picture that they liked because she
started getting annoyed i was like hey i
want you to tag me on twitter
and like post this picture
and so she's like she'll do it and so
for the whole weekend me and my friends
kept trying to look up these two dudes
after googling them seeing if like if it
ever showed up and it never did that's a
shame they must have figured it out
we appreciate the story
and um that's pretty cool though that
some mistook you for some you know big
beautiful uh celebrity and i think you
are a big beautiful celebrity
and um i would take a photo with you if
i ever saw you knowing full damn well
that you are mega awesome nerd
thank you for the story
no
problem it's over if it's over we'll
take that picture
we'll snap that for sure
don't come to my house though i'll come
to you don't come to me
yeah no that's that's weird yeah all
right take care thank you
fantastic
hannah
we've got
hannah 21 years old have a funny story
about when you were in veterinarian
veterinary assistant class oh i didn't
know that was a class what what kind of
class is that in high school
so basically it was the first year our
um school ever offered it because it was
not funded prior
um so it was a [ __ ] show basically from
the get-go
interesting okay let's do it eh let's do
it okay hannah you know the rules you
get one minute from the time we ring the
bell if you make me laugh you got 100
are you ready
i am ready man ring that mother loving
bell okay count you in in three two one
go
okay so we showed up to the class um
prior to this day we had only practiced
giving shots to oranges so our teacher
thought that it would be a great idea
that we were able to um go to a farm
that he had found with some cowboy with
some random ass goats to give them shots
because he thought we were prepared to
do that you know yeah um so we yeah we
ride we get in these like creepy raper
bands that apparently our school had
provided for us and all these 17 18 year
olds hop up in these vans with
teachers this wasn't um like a a loud
field trip either so we just sketchily
rode off in these vans with our teacher
to this farm so we get there and this um
cowboy dude is like all right you guys
are ready to artificially inseminate
these oh
no way
and we're like what
so they pick me to go first and i get
this needle and then i jam it into this
goat but they have some thick-ass skin
so i start pushing the syringe and all
this goat just starts falling down the
side of this poor goat onto my shoes i'm
wearing like holy sneakers so it's like
that's time but
keep going
i think we need a sound effect for
time's up so we can just let them
something quicker you know it's like
beep anyway keep going i'm fascinated by
the story
yeah so there's dripping down this porgo
it's screaming in pain because you know
it has this thick ass syringe just like
stabbed into it so mr cowboy's like girl
it's a goat just stab it it's not gonna
feel anything you're fine and i'm like
dude i'm sorry i don't want to hurt it
anymore
so
he goes and shows me how to stab it and
then he's like all right now you just
gotta push it in and i'm like all right
sure
um so i thought he was gonna just let me
do it but now he comes over and he like
takes it back out gives it to me makes
me stab this poor goat again where'd you
stab the goat to inseminate it yeah does
that work neck
it's just so weird i don't get it you
you
inserted semen into the neck you know
that's not how procreation works
i don't they said yep we're gonna
artificially inseminate these goats with
a shot to the neck and they're gonna
have some babies man that's that's crazy
you go from orange to stick and needle
and goat neck where do you live
i live in utah
utah
sadly could be more i thought yeah i
mean
[ __ ] you know that's that's so how did
all the other kids do with the uh
assignment
uh i mean the other people in the class
because this like class was led by like
the ffa teacher who's like the future
farmers of america so they're all like
horse girls and like cowboys and they're
like we do this [ __ ] every day we just i
just got done inseminating my goat
myself before i came to school exactly
[Music]
yep
do you feel that you can inseminate a
goat now if you had the opportunity
um
i don't know how well it actually worked
i was never able to see like the end
results you know so i don't know if i
would be able to do it again just
because i don't know how legit the
entire thing was um
well i love the image you got in a rape
you got a rape bus was loaded up with a
syringe of goats and
shocked the goat in the neck with it it
sounds like a good ass time
it was a good senior year day you know
just your normal
high school things
well hannah
fantastic thank you thank you for the
story and um
did the goats were the goats suffering
or they kind of just whatever
they are kind of just like whatever i'm
sure this cowboy like [ __ ] rough
houses them with all the like all the
time you know like throws them on the
ground and ties their legs up and all
that [ __ ] they're like yeah this is just
a normal day well you know the comedy
says hey it's just a goat kind of you
know a little disturbing i mean hey
goats goats are men have you heard
you've heard goats scream they sound
like men
you know yeah and that's what happened
when i first shoved this needle in this
game yeah that sounds like exorcism
noise
goat sounds like a man yeah you better
pull that back we need that
anyway uh this is for you hannah
they're triggering the harsh memories is
that a ptsd yeah
yeah
well hannah
thank you for sharing your story i did
not laugh but i enjoyed every moment of
it so thank you for calling him
thank you thank you take care
my uh i had like some animal ed kind of
stuff what did i figure what they called
it but like dissecting a worm or some
[ __ ] like that you know i never biology
yeah i never rejected semen yeah our our
school my high school actually had that
ffa program that she's talking about so
i i had some friends that were in it and
they they did weird ass [ __ ] like that
but
not
oh [ __ ]
that's a goat
awesome
what is up with the
insemination in the neck though can
someone look that up that's not a thing
right
that sounds insane that doesn't work
like that yeah i mean i don't know a ton
about inseminating goats but that just
that doesn't track with me
i mean hey i'm not a future farmer of
america not an ffa that's true could be
totally wrong on this one
well i'm i'm actually
i'm gonna save these other ones we've
got a few other ones
i'm gonna save them for next week
uh
that's okay if you want to save them i
don't know if we're going to be doing
this next week because a it is
thanksgiving next week oh my goodness
uh i don't know if i should reveal this
but you're you're doing someone else's
podcast next wednesday
today's wednesday
so i'm doing someone else's podcast on
wednesday
yeah i don't know if well we could do it
on a different day we could do it on
like
we could theoretically do it on a
different day but you're right
thanksgiving kind of throws a wrench in
things eh yeah it's going to be let's
finish them out then
i need more water though hold on one sec
okay so uh
what's up dan hey
how you doing man
what's up everybody uh ethan stepped
away for a second oh
oh
what is this zach
what you got yeah funky with it man
[Music]
so zach why'd you use a sound bite of me
during uh during an egg middle piece
oh you're gonna go pee
we got this we got this
[Music]
it's a quick break everybody just quick
break
let me throw uh
a b let's see some moves
[Music]
yeah let's see what you got
let's see what you got
oh he's going here we go
oh
what
get it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] let's give it up for a b let's give
it up for a b in the chat everybody a
little love for a b
ian
yeah where's he yeah you got some moves
you want to share with dancing with your
cat what you got
you and ruben
kept flipping the [ __ ] out
[Music]
some good news dude
[Music]
you good you good again
[Music]
wow
that's uh let's uh give it up for uh ian
and um reuben reuben
he just adopted his cat uh very recently
so congratulations to
him and his girlfriend for their first
child
and they're uh they're very proud very
proud
and uh zach
what you got
show me what you got go
yep
yep oh oh oh zack zack
oh no
[Music]
all right zach keep it
together
i walk away for one moment and zach's
taking his shirt off
you know i didn't have coffee this
morning i didn't have time so i'm
actually going to bust out my
oh it is
liquid
energy same color
and my glass of water here to help pick
me up so we can finish this up but this
uh
it's green
i like green
all right
thank you guys for holding that down
well i uh
a b showed us some serious moves he's
got the jackson moves can i see hit me
with that
well just give me a quick preview i'll
do it again really
i mean
it's a little tacky i command you you
can go watch the vod
go ahead i'm gone again i need more
water oh my god
what is it
we want to see damp again he's waiting
for me to dance yeah dance
all right
round two here we go
oh
i forgot you're like a michael jackson
simp
i know i never said that we got a
disagreement about some things but that
was a michael jackson dance move bro
everyone knows michael jackson dance
moves
i mean i know them i don't know if i
could do that actively practicing them
they could just as easily be called
chris brown moves but i don't know if
that's
with you and these problematic dancers
yeah what's bro you pic pick your
fighter michael jackson or chris brown
we're gonna have to have a debate some a
michael jackson debate someday but i
think that's a dead meme i don't know
how i feel about you simply literally
and michael jackson no i don't like
chris brown
michael jackson who do you like better
me or michael jackson
you
wow no hesitation thank you damn i've
never [ __ ] a little boy
michael jackson don't pay the bills
he's got a good point you know he knows
who uh pays his right he would though he
would pay your bills if you met him a
little younger if you were like eight
years old he'd pay all your [ __ ]
bills to europe
i just said the guy i never mind i don't
want to get into i'm just this is really
good by the way it tastes great
i'm not this is i'm not even this is
lemon ginger
matcha
i don't know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
ginger
tastes great
i'm i'm pepped up i'm ready to go all
right
let's uh let's finish it off legend of
the grind seth 22 years old
has a story involving his truck
and his high school play
that he thinks will make me laugh seth
are you with us today
yeah i'm with you i'll tell you though
i'm feeling less confident about making
you laugh after hearing all these other
stories but we'll give it a shot it's
been a tough it's been a tough day i
don't know
you know i think
i think by myself i i'm very this is
very challenging i think and i'm afraid
you know i need to loosen up a little
bit
maybe smoke some weed before or
something
it's funny though you keep you keep
saying it's a tough crowd today but like
technically you're you're the tough
crowd you are trying to make you laugh
yeah i'm the tough crowd
well seth i have faith in you
all right i'll give it a shot you know
the rules when the bell rings you do
your thing you get one minute if you win
you get a hundred crisp
juicy
dollar
bells all right seth yes please all
right all right i will count you in here
we go
coming to you in three two one
so when i was in high school i had a
huge diesel truck that uh i pretty much
drove is like a joke because anyone who
knows me knows i'm like a soft boy who
does not fit the stereotype of a truck
driver
but uh the same year i had that truck i
i was in the school play it was charlie
brown play
and uh i i was playing linus and so
on the way back from practice one night
i'm at a red light
and these proud boys these redneck proud
boys rebel flags pull up in their truck
next to me and they start screaming and
yelling at me then they want to race and
i'm not about to do that
so i lean out in my window and my full
line is
face makeup hair i even had the blanket
around me and i just calmly say no
thanks i'm good
they just went like dead quiet for like
five seconds and then drove away flicked
me off and said [ __ ] you linus
and that was kind of like the highlight
of my life
[Laughter]
you technically laughed within the one
minute but i i it seemed to be from the
rice gum laugh more so than from the
story listen linus is the stinky one or
the good with the no no he's the one
with the blanket yeah he's the kid he's
uh lucy's younger brother
yeah
and i'm like six three two so like it's
it's kind of you don't expect someone
like me to play linus and you definitely
don't expect someone like me to
roll down the window is this uh
was this uh you're a good man charlie
brown is that the show you're doing yeah
it was yeah
well i love the story
and uh
i'm thinking i'm internalizing it you
know
um
those rednecks they probably thought you
were one of them right
yeah i'll tell you dude i'm here in uh
south carolina and uh oh yeah
trucks are everywhere and uh you know i
i specifically had a truck that was like
a coveted truck it was like a
ram 2500
um and
the reason i had it is because my dad
drives trucks and it was his old car and
he was giving it to me until i could get
my own
so uh yeah they did they thought i was
one of them and i kind of knew that and
i was gonna kind of play with uh that
idea and surprise them when i wrote on
the window and have like rosy red cheek
makeup and
blanket around my neck
when did this happen recently
no so this was
oh man probably five years ago so this
is pre magga
yeah
well uh
it was yeah he wasn't elected yet but
there's there's still tons of trump
those red flags tell me what's it like
down there now that the what's mega
country like these days after uh um
yeah so uh
pretty much
uh no one accepts it
no one's taking any of their signs down
uh
it's just
specifically on on my commute to school
every day there's this one house that
has like the entire yard just plastered
in trump signs and
um you'd think they would at least take
some of them down but i i don't think
any of them believe it yet
so you say a lot of the a lot of the
mega crowd down there i've been
wondering myself how many people are
kind of accepting the results it's
interesting to have this perspective you
think the majority of trump supporters
down there
are not accepting the results of the
election
so i mean i know in the podcast the
other day you guys kind of i think uh
dan gave a statistic i think it's true
like there's there's only a few that
think he won but a lot of them
it's not like over yet
right yeah there was like a much bigger
chunk that said like
it's still tbd versus i think it was
only like three percent say like no
trump won
isn't that what which state is lindsey
graham from that's south carolina yeah
that's that's mine what it was i cannot
believe he won again he was running
against so like let me tell you this is
how racist south carolina can be
so
jamie harrison was a guy who's running
against yeah and this guy
he's democrat but he's play he played to
the middle so well he didn't have any
extreme views
and people
here hate lindsey graham and they still
voted for him because they'd rather vote
for him than for a black guy
i'm convinced that's what happened
lindsey graham is very entrenched i mean
he's a big player right in the
republican party that would have been a
huge upset i really liked his challenger
he seemed like a real smart capable guy
but
are you are you are you is your family
mega are you kind of the black sheep
so yeah i am uh
um
my so
yeah they they they have the whole idea
of like uh we're voting for the party
not the person but i mean that's that's
kind of not true so yeah but uh what
about max yeah yeah are people very
careful
down there
um
not really no
i was uh
um my school just hit i actually got
coveted a few weeks ago because my
school isn't taking it seriously oh dude
you shouldn't be catching covert at
school that's so [ __ ]
yeah yeah i mean we were we're wearing
masks but like that's that's really it
and
even um even some of the students just
refused to wear them
but in general here it's yeah the masks
thing isn't great
but you've got to think like there's
probably a lot of people catching covet
around there are people not being like
okay at what point do people say okay
this is this is you know a lot of us are
in the hospital
a lot of us have covid
people don't seem to care you think
people will never accept it you know
i've heard anecdotes of people on their
death bed saying
still refusing to believe they have
covet
uh there was a nurse that that put out a
story saying
you know she sees people dying
in the hospital still refusing to
believe that
that they're dying of govid
and that it's a conspiracy all the way
to their until their death
yeah i mean there's a
a guy actually like confronted me the
other day he was like why are you
wearing a mask why are you buying into
all this oh no
were you like dude i literally had cobin
yeah i told him i was like i had it and
he was like yeah my daughter has it
right now i was like wait then what are
you saying oh my god
i i don't i don't know what to do on
this planet man yeah
yeah i'm at a loss you know it's like
man it's i love it frustrating
yeah
myrtle beach has like the highest
numbers too at least this summer and
that's that's here in south carolina wow
because everyone's like let's go to the
beach
they're incoming
you know i'm not asking you to be like a
[ __ ] libtard i you know i just don't
know why i'm wearing a mask and being
safe is turned into some kind of [ __ ]
political uh point that people need to
make
uh but yeah but you're out there you're
crazy you're doing it and uh i'm glad
you're okay i have a fiat now by the way
i i do not i was actually gonna ask you
i was gonna ask you once you got it okay
you really hate it there man
[Laughter]
dude i don't know i'm gonna i'm i'm
trying to come down to where you guys
are one day in california i feel like i
thrive there that's the [ __ ] problem
though is because all the same people
right
who have who who who are [ __ ] normal
people who understand you have to wear
masks they all leave
to la and new york or wherever else
chicago and then you know
south carolina is just stuck with a
bunch of [ __ ]
jelly-brained idiots who just want to
walk around without masks
right yep
so that's a good point
there's gonna be a civil war there's
gonna be giant earthquake california's
gonna break off from the country and you
can come surf with us here
yeah that's all i'm gonna do for the
world
yeah sounds good you know
look there's nothing wrong with being
conservative i have a lot of
conservative uh
views on on on certain things but man
but honestly sure my thing i just want
people to arrive to those opinions
critically by critically thinking and i
don't feel like a lot of people here do
i think they just do it as a personality
thing
yeah you definitely fit in i mean it's
hard it's hard it's hard not to fit in
you know
i have to give you guys some it's hard
especially when people are so
mega magga baby well keep it keep it you
know what um
seth let's keep seth great again keep
seth great
hey i'm down with that no i'm working on
a dude self-care it's that's that's what
it's all about
i love that you're in a fiat man
that's great congrats on the fiat
all right dude take care god bless you
seth thanks a lot all right thanks a lot
see you yeah i don't think seth made me
laugh i think zach made me laugh
to be totally frank
man i
it's crazy dude it's like a whole
different world in places like south
carolina i just i don't even i just
don't get it dude just wear a mask
i don't understand people say mask is
just a control thing like like
to control what like what's the end game
here i feel like what's the conspiracy
i'm sure
on the whole there are plenty of people
that are still very anti-mass but i i do
get the feeling that that's subsiding a
bit in like the last month or so i mean
i've been hearing i don't think in uh
the dakotas they're now gonna mandate
masks which they were like
super antimatter government officials
but like i don't i think there's but i
think the tide is shifting and you know
it is as
subtle as it is but i think you know
the
pence and trump and stuff you see them
on tv wearing masks sometimes
now whereas you didn't at all before
and i think it's you know
the fur around that is hopefully dying
down a little bit never forget donald
[ __ ] donald he's such a douche coming
out of the hospital with kovid and then
taking his mask off like the messiah the
masculist messiah he's like
after they pumped his veins full of
adrenal chrome to literally baby stem
cells i feel so powerful
baby stem cells that you yourself wanted
your party wants to defund it's awesome
that's so cool
nothing matters rad okay
yeah you know we're i know we're doing a
fun show but trump is such a [ __ ]
loser sorry
he literally isn't doing anything since
he lost his schedule is empty he's doing
nothing he plays golf every [ __ ] day
he is completely advocating all
responsibility all day and on top of
that he's like nobody likes me he's like
i'm not going to be president anymore
during the most critical time to be
president maybe in the past hundred
years we have this vaccine coming up we
need to mobilize it not only am i not
gonna give a [ __ ] about being president
i'm gonna block joe biden from also
doing anything too
blocking the transition i mean what a
[ __ ] douche
douche of the century
just give you a big fat kiss
he is funny though yeah he's great can
never take that away he's definitely
gonna make a reality show or news
network or something but whatever it is
i'm sure it will go bankrupt within five
years because everything he does goes
bankrupt in five years everything
i don't know about this time
he didn't have like a cult the way he
does now he'll find a way to go bankrupt
by whatever he will find a way to ruin
it maybe
i mean his
i like people i like the theory that
he's just going to like uh
continue to act as if he's president for
the next four years and be kind of like
an anti-president like how there was an
anti-pope at one point in the history of
the catholic church there was yeah so
he'll just be like the anti-president
he'll
to the transition and the government
that he needs so that he can actually
[ __ ] govern and mobilize you know
distributing the vaccine is going to be
one of the biggest logistical challenges
that humanity has ever faced
and uh
he people need to be working on that
people need to be working on that right
now
i want that vaccine you know that new
one was ninety-five percent effective
i'll tell you that right
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll take all of
them
i'm over this [ __ ] i'm done man
yeah
on to the next ball all right who's next
now that we've brought the mood way down
i'm over it
okay we have nicole
uh nicole 18 years old
hi nicole
hi can you hear me i can hear you
beautifully crisp and clear how are you
today perfect
good how are you as i understand it you
choked in a restaurant and you think
that was funny
uh it wasn't me actually
oh someone else joked in a restaurant
yes someone else choked in a restaurant
well nicole you know the rules when the
bell rings you have one minute to make
me laugh you make me laugh you got a
hundred freaking
dollars
real bucks all right
nicole are you ready
i am ready all right let's get started
one minute on the clock starting in
three two one go
all right so when i was like 10 years
old my family went to this restaurant to
meet my dad's friend and his wife from
out of town
and we all got like appetizers and stuff
and then my dad's friend's wife started
choking on her salad
like seriously choking and couldn't
breathe and a waiter had to come over
and do the heimlich and she threw up
which was good because like she could
breathe again but she threw up basically
what she had just eaten from her salad
right on top of her salad and then
continued to eat it and she was so
traumatized that she like didn't notice
what was going on and no one said
anything and i had like a huge fear of
vomit at the time so i was sobbing and
my dad had to just go like oh she just
she had a rough day
and like she she she just ate the whole
thing and it was horrifying now was it
like chunky puke was it like puke puke
she threw up basically like leaves and
dressing oh and then she read it and not
no one said anything
because no because they was just their
favorite
that's time their family had been
through like a traumatic
thing
recently and it was one of their first
outings since then god these poor people
yeah
whatever whatever was dramatic this was
this sounds even more traumatic i mean i
can't imagine eating my puke just had a
sheer shock right eating my pupils yeah
all and she just didn't notice that she
had done it i guess because it like
choking i guess you kind of like but you
were sitting there crying just bawling
yeah i was like 10 years old and i had a
huge fear of vomit so i was like curled
up next to my dad and he was he was like
oh she just does this sometimes like oh
jesus
come on dad
have you gotten over your duke
yeah yeah i'm i'm good now okay had you
puke uh have you puked uh
since then have you puked
uh
actually last night i think i ate
something gross and i woke up at like
five and threw up oh
wow sorry to hear that but but you're
but you're over the phobia that's the
good part
yeah i don't care now i'm
i've had to be around it more growing up
i guess excellent you know ela my wife
hila you may know her
uh she has never puked not once
yeah i i'm
a long time
listener of everything so i
i've heard is that so odd she's never
puked i don't believe it i swear to god
i've known her
dan for so long one time she she drank
too much back back back in the day and
her stomach was [ __ ] up we went in the
bathroom and i tried to make her puke i
jammed my fingers down her throat
because i was like you drink too much
you need to puke and she she would not
puke she's she's incapable of puking
what does she is she like weird with
puke because she's never no she's not
weird about puke
she's not worried about theodore pukes i
puke she cleans it up she's she's she's
no problem with bu
interesting [ __ ]
yeah it's you know clean up your piddle
like when you puke all over yourself
even that's really sweet of her
sure she cares wait what dan nothing
never mind
um
um
it concerns me frankly that because i
mean you really need to be able to puke
if you need to but yeah
yeah well i'm glad you can
nicole thank you
thank you and uh how's that lady doing
is she still what's what's her status
the puke lady uh i honestly have no idea
i
don't keep up with my dad's friends very
much and they live like across the
country so it's i don't really see them
but she's alive as far as i know okay do
me a favor ask your dad if he remembers
that tonight and uh report back to us i
will
yeah i will okay nicole
thank you for sharing i did not laugh
but i appreciated the story and i loved
it very much
yeah i i appreciate you sticking around
and i i just want to say before i go
right when the teddy fresh sale happened
i
chose to get a sweatshirt instead of
grocery shop so i've been like
scrounging
and i got a
don't do no like it was good it was good
i have food i'm not like i'm good but
i'm
i i just chose to do that and i'm very
excited my sweatshirt comes tomorrow
well i hope that it meets your
expectations and thank you for
supporting us in that way but it does
make me sad to hear that you forego
essentially no no like i i had food
stored up i was just like oh should i
like i'm sending you a hundred bucks
yeah i'm sending you you win damn it
okay get it wow just like that giving
you a hundred bucks
yeah yeah
you got me with the pin yeah yeah take
it all right all right i mean it was a
great story you gotta all right come on
can't be having to buy teddy fresh
instead of groceries it's outrageous
send her a hundred bucks would you
please dan
okay
for me personally or yeah yeah yeah your
money okay she didn't make me laugh
right
thanks dan all right you got it bye
nicole take care god bless
[Music]
it's very magnanimous of you okay
uh finally we've got abs video ab do you
want to set this up or should i just let
it roll you can let it roll i put a
little title card in there
fantastic here we go
a b for a hundred dollars
sorry i don't know why i did that
i mean that's what it sounded
all right here we go 400 bucks a b
guy who looks like abe drops the ball at
an arab version of american idol
i had a big smile on my face
but with a hundred dollars on the line
ab you know i don't [ __ ] around
one of you guys show me that oh you know
what i owe that one guy he donated 100
bucks and we never watched the fire
video and i saw people saying oh
was it the turkish fire safety right
yeah i never watched it so here's the
here's what i'm going to pledge because
as they if somebody wants to make me
laugh just show me this
you know i thought about just throwing
that in there but i thought that was
cheating so like
so if i laugh at this i'm going to try
my best because i love this video it's
like my favorite video on the internet
let's pay that guy you have his do you
know who he is
uh no okay let's just watch that
hundreds watch
the fire safety exhibition
the first demonstration doesn't go so
well
the extinguisher seems to spread the
planes better than it douses them i love
it it's already so good nobody gets hurt
the fire extinguisher doesn't even work
at this [ __ ] up
demonstration
oh yeah
fire and fear create chaos
there's too much fuel on the wood
ah the fire by the way he scoops it it's
too good he should go
watch it why would he do this
he literally just douses those bags and
[ __ ] you
oh
so funny
man i hope they don't have fires in
turkey
there's a fire in turkey their whole
country is going to burn to the floor
don't send that guy
i love this video man like the way he
scoops it like it's an assassination
attempt really it's too much that's
attempted murder bro
he's like all right let's
let's scoop this fire on this [ __ ]
guy right here
it's like a special attack in a video
game like a rpg
scoop fire on enemy
[ __ ] you
oh so [ __ ] good man
so there you go the guy got all right
well if that guy
if you reach out to one of us
and can prove it with you we'll uh we'll
have two more we have two more
let's bring them out james sweaty
cuttlefish
23
has some dad jokes that he thinks can
make ethan laugh fantastic i love the
original comedy that sounds fan great
james are you with us
yeah dude cool
so are these original jokes are these
just from like jokes.com
these are jokes that i spent at least
three minutes googling
oh okay
okay james yeah well let's queue you up
you know the rules when you hear the
bell you have 60 seconds to make ethan
laugh if you make even laugh you get a
hundred dollars if you don't we
incinerate you that's right
oh okay go away win win all right all
right james here we go country in in
three two one go
what do you call someone with no body
and no nose
what nobody knows
[Music]
you know i used to hate facial hair
but then it grew on me
got him
how many
how many
tickles does it take
to make an octopus laugh
how many ten tickles
ten ten pickles got it good one
sorry
i don't trust stairs
no they're always up to something
that's true
you know people say that they pick their
nose
i just feel like i was born with mine
right because you don't because it's
[Applause]
correct
you know how do you get a squirrel to
like you
how's that
how does a penguin
build this house how's that
it glues it together
close it together
bruh
igloos oh igloo
did you ever hear
about the guy who invented the knock
knock joke i have it
he won the nobel prize
um
nobel she's knocking
yeah you know i've actually got a great
joke about construction but still
working on it right sure
thank you
all right
yeah i like your delivery can you hear a
psychologist using the bathroom
say again
why can't you hear a psychiatrist using
the bathroom why is that
because the p is silent
the p
is silent
in psychiatrists
right
your delivery is really good i like the
uh the computer i like how you um
you uh reflect on everything
hmm very good yeah well you know i'm
disappointed with a hundred bucks you
know you're out here with your zoom
background
trying to
hey this is a set how dare you hey we
spent a lot of time on this dude get him
off the line get him off get him behind
give him the hook how dare you
get the [ __ ] out cut him out thank you
james thanks for those jokes that was
fun didn't laugh
tough crowd today as you guys know it's
tough out here
but james really good delivery and i had
a lot of fun on to our last contestant
giacomo
italiana gramma
you're going you're going to bring this
up
you don't want to bring this out oh no
look what we've done
oh you kidding me
29 years old
he's a very funny bathroom story that he
thinks he can make ethan laughs
giacomo are you italian
yes i am indeed
in case the accent didn't say the name
was pretty much
you have an act you have an accent are
you from italy are you an immigrant yes
i am are you calling me
i'm i'm living currently in italy i've
always had i don't know if my parents
maybe adopted me i don't know but i
don't think so
you are caught we have a fan from italy
calling right now this is exciting what
time is it there
it's 23 or 11 p.m
can i ask you something
would you consider if somebody said hey
fredo would you consider that an a race
uh
a uh ethnic insult if somebody called
you fredo
well i don't even know what i don't even
know what the alfredo thing is about
i think it's an italian-american thing
from godfather fredo was like the
fuck-up son
oh yeah yeah yeah i got yeah i mean if
if someone was saying like yeah i think
the
the great
lynching of louisiana was rightful then
then that would be racist yeah but just
like joking you know no but they say i
think people do sometimes use it very
mean
so i i actually i think it's quite a
mean insult i was just kind of curious
what's your take on it
yeah but
maybe for an american in
italian
how's everything in italy
you guys are kind of going through you
guys went through a really bad covid
situation and it's going back to it
again we are 40 000 cases per day now oh
man but
we are also divided in zones like my
region is a yellow region okay but it's
surrounded by orange and red
regions and we're going like that that
is like the
hour at risk the thing is in comparison
on the number of the beds on at the
hospital pretty much
so green is the cleanest
number in the green zone anymore and red
is in the
it's the highest
well
i hope you stay safe and uh i think it's
great it's exciting to get a call from
italy
jack
yeah i mean i can't stay only so much
safe because
i currently working in retails
and i until the 12th of the october i
was working with parents
store which is a grocery store so pretty
much every day is
going out for me it's not like oh boy i
only have so much
risk they can take and not take you know
yeah i mean listen you gotta work you
gotta support yourself what can you do
but uh yeah well
giacomo
let's get you a hundred bucks huh what
do you think
uh yeah sure let's get it all right
giacomo you know the rules when you hear
the bell
you have 60 seconds to make either live
you come to me
on this very special occasion please
yes stan
all right i'll catch you in here we go
giacomo let's go in three two one go
okay this happened back in university i
was alone in the bathroom right before
class taking a pee in the in a urinal
completely zoned out while i was paying
someone taps on my shoulder making me
snap out of trends with my sp it was
still on my hand
i turned around and i noticed it's a
girl in the bed in the bathroom next to
me she goes hey i know it's confusing
but they changed the bathroom this is
the girl's bathroom now and it's a
urinal [ __ ] god damn it i was shocked
i don't know if i said anything but if i
did i was like yelling at their face no
sorry
so i ran to my class and i i take a seat
right before class that the seat next to
me was um like empty but there was a bag
on it and as you can guess it was hers
so i was then stuck for 1.5 hours next
to this girl that saw my winner pretty
much
and then uh she was the worst part is
like she was being nice and it was like
it's okay don't worry forget about it
it's a mistake you know all the stuff
but at every single one of her world i
just want to like to stop myself
in the
in the chest because i i've never felt
that embarrassment before
and i don't
so sir again go ahead i'm sorry to
interrupt you give him a little more
time
no
we're actually past time so it's okay
but go ahead
yeah she
like she was like trying to be nice with
me
but of course that was like just making
everything worse
because
you know i
i was forced in class to even make eye
contact with a person that i really
wanted to avoid at that point so did she
saw your wiener how come she did you
fully turned around
because you know it was a you we didn't
actually have like separator in the
urinal between the urinals oh
wait so yeah did they really switch up
the female and male bathroom and they're
yeah what the hell kind of [ __ ] is
that
i mean either i think they wanted to
like make change they work on bathroom
later on but this was very italian
public working times so it like it would
the bedroom stayed with female having
urinals and boys having no urinals for
like two years
before that changed when you say when
you say italian public time you mean
everything goes really slowly
sorry again when you said uh italian
public time you mean everything goes
really slowly
yeah there is this road
um that has been finished in 2005 and it
was started in 1979
yeah that's kind of infamous
yeah it's like
because it's all on someone doesn't pay
and then you don't you know all the [ __ ]
i got a big soap
what part of italy do you live in i
really want to visit there should i
visit there or should i save my time
what do you think
well i'm living near rome but my town
is famous for a garden an artificial
garden
that
was built here from and speaking of um
uh the anti-pope that you were referring
to before then um actually that that you
the dude that was not the antipope but
the regular pope bonifas the eighth he
was from my zone
all the family kaitani they were from
here
and
but yeah
i live near to rome and i was in
university in rome
uh i wouldn't visit i mean yeah it's
beautiful if you're busy like a week
you heard it from giacomo don't visit
italy
yeah you can uh
i will can i i shout out to my
mothers or if you want to help my
business
if you ever pass near me
you can go the fruitery elementary
patricia antonella and i can give you
the address next okay i think i'll
definitely look you up
all i heard was
i love that sound pussycloth all right
giacomo it's been great getting to know
you thank you for listening all the way
from italy that's so cool
i appreciate that stay safe man
thank you man and uh god bless stay safe
over there okay
viva la italy or whatever that's the
wrong language but you get the idea
all right
sure all right take care giacomo
jacobo
you
[Applause]
to make me laugh
[Music]
he thought of making me laugh huh
he don't make me laugh
it is a very funny story about the
golden state of venus
what's that
zach no
zack no
[Music]
please you play it
you come to my show
make ethan laugh but you do not make me
laugh
why
why
why do you not make me laugh
make ethan laugh when you don't make me
laugh it doesn't make sense
i even offer you a hundred dollars
no
no
giacomo my brother get out
why have you done this
this music's great
hey dan how much money we give away
today what's the damage oh
uh
300 that's it
yeah i mean oh man am i right
i believe so you guys are wondering if
you caught if you cut with zach right oh
400 was zach yeah you don't have to give
me the hundred bucks it's okay shut up
you don't make a lot of god to make you
laugh i'm gonna give you 100 bucks dude
we're playing a game here i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
so not as bad as you feared 400 bucks i
mean
well i don't know was i was i quite grim
today or was yeah yeah
well i mean that's that's part of it too
i mean it shouldn't be easy you are kind
of hard to make laugh i mean that's it's
true because previously
i was laughing at everything but i i got
to get a little more serious for this
show because if i'm laughing at
everything it's not that interesting
right
right true
i had some highlights though
i think you know my favorite column was
probably if i can
award in a uh
i think lizzy
the
modeled or whatever yeah
that was definitely one the arby's
number one did she get you
i think she did yeah she got me to laugh
yeah yeah uh she did
we have a ton i got a ton of messages
coming in i couldn't really get to all
of them during the show but next time we
do it well guys i hope we can figure out
a time to do it next week i know next
week is thanksgiving but if we can't
figure it out next week we are going to
be doing this on a weekly basis how was
the reception what were people enjoying
it i feel like people were liking it
right chat let us know
let us know if uh
well we'll see the the people in the
comments will tell us the people who are
chat
also i think um you know
we
we are going to figure this out more and
more as we go along uh i mean
if other people
want to do something like what cam
grants did uh create some sort of video
content
that's definitely a favorite yeah that
was great yeah but yeah that's just
something to keep in mind everybody is
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
story if you if you've got some sort of
um
i think we should restrict it from being
like sending videos of somebody else's
video but if you create some sort of
original content and then you want to
send that in to try and walk you through
it if you have a really unique video
that i've probably never i mean i've
seen so many of these internet videos
but submit whatever you got submit it to
the guys and that if they think it's
good
we'll watch it
okay
you know yeah but basically if you want
to be featured on a future episode
become a member
and submit to zach or a b
or dan or not dan zachary i mean you
could submit it to me but i'm probably
just zack sort of the the kingpin of um
setting up the gatekeeper yeah he's the
gatekeeper so so you can submit it to
zach via dm and um we're gonna keep
lining people up every week to win even
the money
come on
have a great thanks we'll be back on
friday
we'll be back on friday with after dark
and they'll be for sure and other
frenemies before thanksgiving and
possibly another one of these streams
and maybe even something else yeah
something else we're always thinking
we're always in the laboratory here at
the h3 nation yeah we're still uh
experimenting with formats as you all
can see and um
that's probably going to continue well
i'm trying to find formats that hit
right like you know frenemies hits after
dark hits
so those two are great
and um so we're trying to find formats
that people really like so i'm just
trying to experiment with all kinds of
different things so if you like it let
me know
you know let the people know i think it
will get better though
obviously
we get you know this is our first step
but i had a lot of fun thank you to
everybody who participated
you all made it
great
and um
looking for the next one so make sure to
apply
with zach if you want to call in yes
please dm me on discord all right y'all
catch you on friday
see you then guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you